Is it OK to use your eyeshadow from a year ago
or what about this old cheese lurking in the fridge?
A smart label could one day tell you when
it's time to throw something away
and when to consume it.
That’s the hope of a team of researchers
who have developed a paper sensor
containing nanostructures that change color
when they bind to compounds that indicate spoilage
such as free radicals
or food contaminants we can't see or smell.
Currently available sensors use liquid solutions
that migrate on a channel.
The newly developed sensor has all the reagents
incorporated in a small piece of paper.
This means it can be directly applied
onto samples that need to be tested.
Down the road, a smart label made from this paper
could indicate how safe it is to use your that mascara
or drink that milk.
These sensors could be also used
to identify new medicinal plants
or natural sources of antioxidants in remote areas
such as the Amazon rainforest.